Speaker 1: Paul Boyer is an Arizona state
senator who originally was supportive of the
Arizona recount of the 2020 election, which
we recently discussed, which is looking at
things like bamboo fibers on ballots in Maricopa
County.
Paul Boyer was supportive of that originally.
And that very same state senator now says
he regrets his support of that movement and
that it, quote, makes us look like idiots.
It's, I guess, like a moment of clarity in
a sea of absurdity in Arizona.
And of course, he's absolutely correct, but
really only at the micro level.
And what I mean by that is that, yes, the
individuals who supported this nonsense and
I mean Josh Hawley in the U.S. Senate, people
like Paul Boyer in the Arizona State Senate,
the whole lot of them, they do look like idiots.
He's right about that.
But the problem is that we as a country look
like idiots internationally, globally because
of these people.
Now, the full quote from Senator Paul Boyer
is it makes us look like idiots.
I didn't think it would be this ridiculous.
It's embarrassing to be a state senator at
this point.
Now it's all great.
Paul Boyer came to realize this.
He's now saying it's a bad idea.
OK, but you can't simply disown the entire
movement that you started simply because it
imploded in shame.
And what I mean by that is that Paul Boya
is reacting to the outcome of this movement.
Imagine if somehow I mean, it would have been
a tragedy nationally, but imagine if they
had found a way, a bogus way to change the
outcome of a state where they figured out
a way.
Wow.
Even though Biden won Arizona, they figure
out some way to flip it to Donald Trump or
imagine if they had been able to do it in
enough states to actually flip the election
from Joe Biden to Donald Trump.
He wouldn't be saying that we looked like
idiots.
He'd be saying we did something heroic, even
though the truth in either case is that Joe
Biden won.
And being able to flip the results or even
trying to do so is a trash garbage movement.
He's trying to disown it now because it failed
and because it didn't go anywhere and because
it's become this national and global laughingstock.
And so he wants to wash his hands of it now
because it failed to to achieve excuse me,
what he wanted it to achieve, at least initially.
And at some point, they need to accept that
they are, number one, wrong on the facts.
And number two, they are idiots because they
fell for it.
It's not just we ended up looking like idiots.
And what's unsaid is in part because this
failed to do anything, it was idiotic to fall
for this from the beginning.
And, you know, looking at Bambu Fiber's, yet
another conspiracy theory.
So the point here is great.
It's always great.
When someone realizes the error of their ways
or of their beliefs and they come to correct
that, that's one of the reasons why science
as a process is so valuable, because it contains
an error correcting mechanism and fixing mistakes
or finding that someone did something wrong,
believe something wrong.
It's rewarded in science.
At least it should be when things go correctly.
But it's not.
You're instantly rehabilitated because one
time much too late.
One seventy percent of Republicans still believe
to this day that Donald Trump actually won
the election and Joe Biden is not the legitimate
president.
Now you say, oh, we look like idiots.
Oh, great.
Wow, you're back.
You're great.
Now, you stumbled into a fact among a sea
of trash propaganda and now you want a cookie.
And this is you know, it's an important analysis
also in the context of the Liz Cheney thing.
The Republican Party are a bunch of hypocrites
when they say they're against canceling people.
And Liz Cheney says, hey, guys, Trump lost
and what he's doing is dangerous and what
he did is dangerous.
You're canceled.
Yes, they're hypocrites.
Liz Cheney is correct that we have a process
in the process worked and we had an election
and we know the results.
She's right about that.
That's it.
She doesn't become a progressive hero.
She is not on the left.
We disagree about just about everything.
And that's an important thing to remember.
When we look at these Maricopa's and we look
at these, I mean, not a term I use, but come
to Jesus moments, do something now to deal
with the systemic fiasco that you was a part
of the Republican Party.
This applies to State Senator Paul Boyer.
It applies to Liz Cheney.
It applies to all of them.
Do something that deals with the systemic
issues.
And then maybe I would find myself having
more praise for you.